so we have more details about what is  happening to joel greenberg in the  northern district  of florida as was suspected he has  signed a cooperation deal with federal  prosecutors number one he is  pleading guilty to six of the 33 counts  that he was charged with  he's admitting that he's paid over 70  000 for over 150 sex acts  that he has defrauded the government  that he has stolen money from taxpayers  in northern florida  and perhaps most importantly he has  agreed to cooperate with federal  prosecutors and of course  uh the papers themselves don't name matt  gates by name  but one has to wonder why would federal  prosecutors  sign a cooperation agreement if he  wasn't agreeing to cooperate against  someone higher up in the food chain and  really  all roads point to matt gates here so in  all likelihood we will probably see matt  gates  in court